alright Jason Segel really funny dude
Emily Blunt cool cute hot and this
movie's directed by the forgetting sarah
marshall guys so it's just looking good
hope it is good the five-year engagement
so the five-year engagement stars Jason
Segel and Emily Blunt and they're
engaged for five years one of those
inadvertently five-year things and then
for it to be like one year and she gets
a promotion and they have to move to
this really small creepy ass town then
you know it ends up being just five
years and was the five-year engagement
good he's not without its moments but
all in all I went to the movie expecting
a comedy I got a drama D almost like
that's a thing in comedies nowadays you
know market the movie as a complete
comedy and then when people go to see it
there's a lot more drama to it and
dramas not bad in comedies really most
comedies have drama in it kind of gives
the movie backbone you know it makes you
care about the characters but sometimes
comedies just go a bit too far with the
drama or it doesn't mix well with the
comedy and you just kind of have a mess
that's a lot more traumatic than you
wanted more or less that's the five-year
engagement someone's like the five-year
engagement was afraid to commit to some
of the jokes you know like the premise
they moved to this small last town so I
had a point Jason Segel has this crazy
pork chop beard mustache thing he's all
hunting all the time they're living like
straight up rednecks that's what happens
when you move to some small last town
from a Stephen King book then at a point
all that goes away now they're just
living normal suburban lives again I was
like alright I guess that was just a
phase that or it was a joke they really
wanted to throw into the movie and then
after the joke was over the joke was
completely over toting the five-year
engagement was really inconsistent mean
the five-year engagement directed by the
guy who directed forgetting sarah
marshall so you think of yourself
alright it's like another sarah marshall
type movie it's almost like this guy was
like alright we're gonna throw a little
more drama on the screen you know we're
really gonna get people invested in
these characters and i just feel like
the movie straight away from what the
director strengths were from Forgetting
Sarah Marshall it's like the movie could
have been and should have been a half an
hour shorter if it was a half an hour
short I'd be like oh it's perfect
instead it's a two hour movie that feels
like a three hour movie for a dramedy
that's not necessarily good so I loved
Jason Segel I loved Emily Blunt I loved
them in this movie I mean they were
really cute together they were a cute
couple they were the strength of the
movie but the movie as a whole is
alright but you're not gonna remember in
t-minus one day yep already forgot
chicks are gonna like it more than dudes
but I'm a dude so that's my rating the
people that went to go see this with
they're a couple and I was like
you guys should relate to this movie
more than me I'm just I'm single you
guys are in a relationship they were
like we don't relate to this [ __ ] we
don't understand this so maybe it's just
unrelatable for most people most people
being three people but that's my survey
three people that's enough for me so
your favorite Jason Segel movie what is
it comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more